i don't know if you've ever watched any
british tv shows or
yeah i've seen a couple have you ever
seen peep show no oh that's good you
should have seen in between us
oh my god you should watch these
pinnacle of french british television
yeah what do you watch like a little
cringe humor
i don't watch any tv really really not
like now no anime do you watch anything
uh anime like the last anime i watched
through was probably like mob psycho i
mean that's honestly that's a good
[ __ ] taste ended up being like the
best one yeah i've seen yourself you
didn't you did cut it off stop it
don't need to look anymore i hit the
peak already yeah i remember that uh i
think we
briefly spoke because you liked banana
fish oh i love banana fish me too but
like it's one of those shows where it
was really underappreciated and people
didn't really talk about it i'm
surprised you watched banana fish
because most anime fans don't know about
banana fish white like that yeah
i think it was just like really [ __ ]
marketed poorly i think it was monsters
like yowie bait kind of yeah yeah
oh if you're a girl and you're like
seeing hot guys have problems well like
it was intentional like twice that was
it yeah but it was a it was a [ __ ]
awesome show it was besides that yeah
that was super cool including that made
elevated by that sure
what other anime have you watched i mean
we obliterally have to talk about it
because yeah because we are technically
animated we never talk about that
um
nothing really good not not a lot of
anime right joey then yeah yeah join the
club yeah
i watched a few episodes of that spy x
family show which was pretty good quite
good i also enjoy food yeah yeah
what's that um
had netflix uh
i don't know if that was an animal okay
no
yeah yes my favorite anime did you like
did you like arcane i loved arcade yeah
me too that was excellent that's great
i had to do it joey i had to do it use
this to watch right it's just funny
it's just funny to see like arcane fans
get pissed off whenever i say that it is
excellent it's a good one um no it was
called uh the great pretender oh yeah
what's the great pretending
that was a good [ __ ] show that was
[ __ ] awesome yeah yeah yeah i did
[ __ ] ending but like a good good
[ __ ] show yeah the way through yeah
that was probably the last one all right
yeah i guess because like i guess it's
it sounds like you watch like a wide
variety of anime just from like
different sources because like banana
fish is like really really [ __ ]
underground apparently yeah how the [ __ ]
is this yeah yeah yeah i don't know it
just came on i i forget where i heard of
it it was good i um
was in the in the mag club in high
school because my friend was the
president of manga anime in gaming
yeah you can't have your separate
clothes it was a bad school it wasn't a
great school really well it's not like
it i mean it was a smaller school so
there's like a harry potter club of mine
yeah just for harry potter that's [ __ ]
up
were you in that [ __ ] no
i don't know you brought it up so i
thought you had some stories the movies
were over at that point i wonder what
they were still talking about oh no i
can't wait fantastic beasts jk rowling
[ __ ] up on twitter again i don't think
so
yeah no yeah i watched the first anime i
ever saw was death note and i would
watch it in my stem class at lunch
because they didn't have a vpm up at the
school right you just stream it at lunch
it was really nice yeah go to the
computer class and just watch what's
what's your favorite anime like of all
time i'm not psycho
yeah that's a very solid season two with
the that animation with that one fight
where they do tell them
rock hard when i think
they're gonna watch season three when it
comes out i didn't know they were doing
a season yeah
it's coming out this year or next year
because they're gonna be the final one
because it's gonna be the final season
yeah that's sick
no i didn't know that
you joined this audio listeners
[Music]
this is giving me really anxiety now
it's what
i've never st i've never seen that smoke
before my glasses what the hell you can
do with any vinyl yeah oh just turn
anything into a [ __ ] gun
is that your like talent
this is super fast
i can immediately put the people around
me in danger
at any point that's why it works
so i i heard a little uh story that you
uh when you got the
boston dynamics dog thing yeah you still
own that right yeah that's around what
do you do with it it's at the offline tv
house right now does it do anything or
um not really i'm still thinking of [ __ ]
to do with it
so i'm just like sitting there just like
he's just waiting to be turned on again
oh no she's like exhausted crying yeah i
see him every time i walk up the stairs
he's like under the staircase oh harry
potter yeah
so did you get that specifically for the
piss robot video idea or did you just
get one and was like i gotta make it it
was like a joint thing with offline tv
right and we all got it together and
then i was like i'll use it for this
this sounds awesome that was right so
you convinced them to pay
yeah because we used it in a couple of
offline tv videos oh really yeah okay so
it was kind of a tax write-off nice this
is melon
can we get a dog
i want a pet
but a very specific kind of pet
i'll get you an intern
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen okay um so i'm
going to i don't know we probably
haven't announced this i'm going we're
going to japan yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah uh i like running off into the
night and doing things i have some
questions about japan okay um if i want
to ride us a motorcycle or a scooter can
i do that can i rent one no no no no no
you need the lighting you need a license
what if i have an international driver's
license maybe they have the uh i can
apply for that they're different but
they have those like ride-on ride-off
like scooters now like electric scooters
that you can drive on the road yeah now
so if you sign up for the apps and you
have a driver's license i'm pretty sure
you can that's cool because i think it's
like a cc thing like a power thing yeah
like anything under like a certain cc
might be allowed yeah i believe so when
you get like a bicycle in japan you have
to register it with the police
like a bicycle yeah yeah you have to
register a bicycle why yeah japan loves
[ __ ] rules there's rules for
everything that sucks yeah i mean it's
like the i guess you get this do you
ever get like arrested for not having
your bicycle i don't know you get your
you get your bike confiscated and
there's like a fine i think
if you get found out you get found out
so japan loves rules yeah and they love
rules so much and that's why everything
works really nicely yeah you're just
like you just like i just wanted to ride
a bicycle i didn't want to have to go to
the police
but that's why i do the rental bicycle
things yeah yeah which are like
everywhere in tokyo yeah so much better
yeah so like
after living in japan i realized the way
the country works is if you want to do
something
um and you ask someone for permission
for it 99 of the time they're going to
say no yeah because they don't know if
you're allowed to do it or not so
they're just gonna say no but if you do
something then there's only like i guess
a 50 50 percent chance that someone's
gonna call you out on it all right yeah
isn't that the way it works right
in japan right yeah like if like you
know there's plenty of irl streamers
yeah you know they never ask for
permission yeah yeah but you know
whenever we do main channel videos or
big things we have to get permission and
it's it's a nightmare japan is literally
better to ask for forgiveness than no
not just like asked to do something yeah
very difficult to get permission to film
in a lot of places because they just
they just don't like no that's yeah
that's tough yeah man
yeah it's just the culture yeah that's
how it is there's ways around it yeah
yeah but you get amazing you know the
trains turn up on time and you so i
guess it kind of works out kind of like
all right yeah everything else works
i'll try to find a scooter
what is what is it that you want to do
in japan then i just want to scoot
around around i just want to see all the
stuff yeah they have the scooter rental
things yeah yeah yeah sucks we're not
there when you guys are there yeah that
is tough we're kind of doing trading
spaces wife swap type thing yeah yeah we
all right yeah yeah could have showed
you around yeah yeah yeah
literally everyone's coming to japan
when we are out of japan yeah it's like
it's it's a [ __ ] mass exodus on both
sides yeah it's so sad i am really
excited for it though i think we're live
have you ever been yes once before okay
it was amazing what did you do there
before uh we went around shibuya i think
shinjuku um tried out the amazing food
tried out the meat that was oh so good
[ __ ] any yoshinoya is just good
hell yeah to me
it is it is it is good
as [ __ ] uh yeah
yeah we did a lot of stuff uh seeing
mount fuji was amazing yeah yeah one of
the most beautiful
things ever so picturesque yeah it's
it's it's like unfair how like pictures
and aesthetic it is it's like god just
like perfectly crafted yeah yeah just
perfect symmetry just a little something
on top yeah yeah let's just add a little
cherry on top yeah i woke up on the bus
and i was like oh this like it's god
that's god
that's like why religion exists
like there was like some lakes around
mount fuji where you walk around and it
literally looks like just it's so
beautiful it literally looks fake yeah i
thought we were at one of those lakes so
it's really beautiful yeah because it
looks like it just looks like it looks
like unreal engine yeah
it looks like a desktop wall
could look like rendered in here okay
unreal engine fire on rtx
how long you guys can be there for um a
while like two weeks solid two weeks
yeah
it's gonna be awesome i i think i might
um just branch off and because probably
my favorite part about japan last time
was um just being by myself in a crowd
of people and no one knowing anything
yeah just being a [ __ ] cog in a
machine was nice that's what it was like
yeah that was cool it was cool like just
like yeah just like floating around in
crowded areas and yeah going to
different
like everyone in la like every single
person you meet it's like you're talking
to like somebody who believes they're
the main character yeah like in every
sense and then in japan it's like i'm
just here to do my part yeah yeah i'm
sure they exist and not get in the way
yeah yeah like it's really like it's
refreshing coming here but then after a
while you're like okay this is too much
yeah i want to go back yeah it's weird
it's definitely strange being in america
now yeah yeah
i'm already [ __ ] sick of the customer
service here or i guess the lack thereof
oh is it because uh yeah because i mean
i feel like we've been spoiled so much
living in japan like with like amazon or
like just going to a [ __ ] restaurant
or whatever but um like yeah what i
thought was normal like next day
delivery yeah on amazon i thought that
was just normal
not not here apparently unless you want
to pay like [ __ ] triple the shipping
yeah it's two days two-day delivery yeah
but in japan it's like 99 times out of a
hundred it's being mixed doesn't make
sense it's just little island i guess it
checks out i guess fishing
shipping is no joke shipping very
seriously yeah